wir haben eine e-mail bekommen von
unseren mitglied und lehrer schreibt ich
möchte euch gerne darum bitten das thema
giering directions in german dazu eine
episode zu drehen und sie sagt ich
arbeite im krankenhaus und kann über
viele themen mit den patienten reden
aber wenn mich einer nach dem weg fragt
wenn ich total verwirrt und kann nur mit
händen und füßen kommunizieren gerne
star wollen wir helfen oh ja sehr gerne
und ich geht geradeaus und danach rechts
christian essig und ihr seht jetzt die
wichtigsten begriffe dazu wie man auch
deutsch nach der richtung fragt los
geht's
jetzt fangen wir an mit den wichtigsten
begriffen
links
rechts
geradeaus
janus geht nach links
janosch geht nach rechts
jetzt zeigen wir euch wie man nach einer
richtung fragt
entschuldigung können sie mir kurz
helfen ich suche diese adresse
entschuldigung wissen sie ob es hier
eine apotheke gibt
entschuldigung kennen sie sich hieraus
ich suche eine apotheke
[Musik]
entschuldigung wissen sie ob es hier in
der nähe eine bäckerei gibt
da gibt es da gehen sie hier links leon
ein stück geradeaus geradeaus und vor
der tankstelle gehen sie rechts
ok danke sehr schönen tag nur gerne
jetzt wieder holen wir noch einmal die
wichtigsten begriffe in der nähe gibt es
hier eine bäckerei in der nähe dann habe
ich geantwortet
gehen sie in diese richtung man kann
auffordern gehen sie oder man kann
einfach beschreiben sie gehen hier
rechts sie gehen geradeaus ein stückchen
geradeaus man kann sagen gehen sie
gerade aus oder gehen sie ein stück
geradeaus das heißt nur ein bisschen
geradeaus
[Musik]
dann ein stück geradeaus
und dann vor der tankstelle gehen sie
rechts
[Musik]
vor der tankstelle rechts
hey das sind sie ja wieder wünsche ich
habe mich total verlaufen in welche
richtung hätte ich laufen müssen von der
tankstelle aus oh
ich hab ich habe mich vertan da gibt es
gar keine bäckerei
aber an der tankstelle gibt es auch
kaffee und brötchen
das werde ich dann machen einfach wieder
in die richtung da gehen viel erfolg
wir wiederholen noch mal die wichtigsten
begriffe
verlaufen ich habe mich verlaufen
die richtung in welche richtung muss ich
gehen
gehen sie in diese richtung
guten tag entschuldigung ich suche nach
ein werkzeug laden es heißt werkzeug bei
der radies 3008 das werkzeug paradies
gehen sie hier rechts geradeaus über die
ampel und dann sehen sie dass auf der
rechten seite auf der rechten seite
klima danke sehr schönen tag noch
wir wiederholen noch mal die wichtigsten
begriffe
suchen ein sehr wichtiger begriff ich
suche ich kann sagen entschuldigung ich
suche diese adresse
das zweite wort ist die ampel oder
ähnlich ist die kreuzung man kann sagen
sie gehen bis zur ampel oder sie gehen
über die ampel oder über die kreuzung
wenn man sagen möchte dass man über die
straße herüber geht und das letzte wort
ist die seite das ist auch wichtig wenn
man eine straßenseite beschreibt man
kann sagen sie finden das geschäft auf
der rechten seite oder
sie finden die adresse auf der linken
seite
entschuldigung ich muss dringend zum
hauptbahnhof können sie mir sagen wie
ich dahin komme der hauptbahnhof ist
aber weit weg haben sie ein auto habe
ich nicht
na ja sie können es mit der u-bahn
wollen sie das mit der u-bahn tja und
sie kommen nicht dahin also die u-bahn
ich schon mal eben also sie gehen hier
bis zur nächsten kreuzung ja und dann
sehen sie an der kreuzung eine
bushaltestelle gegenüber der
bushaltestelle ist oben die u bahn
stationen und dann nehme die u2 bis zum
hauptbahnhof
prima das mache ich denke sehr schönen
tag noch na dann viel glück
wir wiederholen noch mal die wichtigsten
begriffe janisch hat gefragt können sie
mir sagen wie ich dahin komme ein sehr
nützlicher satz für euch wenn ihr etwas
sucht können sie mir sagen wie ich dahin
komme
ein anderer wichtiger ausdruck ist weit
weg ich habe gesagt das ist weit weg
das gegenteil von weit weg ist nah man
kann sagen oh das ist sehr nah oder das
ist um die ecke und der letzte begriff
heute
gegenüber gegenüber ist sehr nützlich
wenn man etwas beschreibt gegenüber
heißt auf der anderen seite zum
abschluss zeigen wir euch noch was man
sagen kann wenn man selber die antwort
nicht weiß ihr könnt zum beispiel das
wert auskennen benutzen es ist ein trend
bares wert ich sage zum beispiel es tut
mir leid ich kenne mich hier auch nicht
aus
oder ihr könnt das wort helfen benutzen
und sagen es tut mir leid
da kann ich ihnen leider nicht helfen
also ich bin gerade ausgegangen und dann
bin ich nach rechts gegangen und dann
war ich da ja das hat ja gut geklappt in
dieser episode wenn ihr selber nochmal
diese ganzen vokabeln die ihr heute
gelernt habe wiederholen möchtet dann
empfehlen wir euch unsere interaktiven
übungsblätter die machen eric und easy
jede woche nur für euch damit ihr die
vokabeln und die ausdrücke aus unseren
videos noch intensiver lernen könnt und
diese übungsblätter bekommt ihr als
mitglied von easy därmen ihr könnt ein
mitglied werden von easy german den link
blenden wir jetzt hier ein damit
unterstützen wir unsere arbeit und lernt
intensiver deutsch
ich gehe jetzt nach rechts oder nach
links ja tschüss bis bald
entschuldigung ich muss dringend zum
hauptbahnhof wenn sie mir sagen wie ich
da hinkommen wenn sie aufhören zu lachen
war mehr menschen
[Gelächter]